should boris johnson resign
well that's what i've said this week
and that was on the back of his fixed
term penalty notices i've always said
that we would wait to see what the
outcome was
and if the prime minister who made the
laws had broken the laws and in my view
he should resign
so the government i guess will argue
that
it's effectively a sideshow he's
apologized there are more important
things to be getting on with with
ukraine in the cost of living you
clearly don't have that perspective why
do you think
that the prime minister needs to go
well i i want the prime minister to take
responsibility for his actions you know
my constituents
like lots of others around the uk went
through some real hardships and
look you know the physical act of what
he's been fined for is kind of
immaterial uh because uh uh you know it
it is excuse expression but it's it's a
birthday cake at the end of the day
but it's the mere fact that he's broken
the rules that he expected everybody
else to to uh adhere to and you know
lots of people lots of families my own
family saw people die couldn't see loved
ones in hospital uh couldn't be with
them when they died and then in some in
many cases couldn't even go to the
funeral so when people have made huge
sacrifices like that it is important
that the prime minister of our country
who is the law maker sticks to the rules
you're talking about you know the
personal stories that people felt during
lockdown with your own family sort of
bereavement
you all the mp for called a valley
relatively you know marginal seat was
held by labour in the past do you
concern that if boris johnson leads the
conservatives into the next election
you might lose it over this
no i don't think it'll come to that i
mean the general election is two years
away and as we know a week is a very
long time in politics so you know it's
not about an eye on the general election
for me it's about actually you know this
government is doing some great things
some huge things huge investment in
places like the call the valley leveling
up agenda infrastructure spend
lots and lots of things going on
but unfortunately as i said yesterday
this is like a very damp
or very wet blanket that is smothering
that story
and we need to move on from it
so tomorrow labour's going to be tabling
this motion to ask mps to vote on
whether or not boris johnson should be
investigated by the privileges committee
about
allegations that he misled the house by
saying that no rules were broken over
partygate how are you going to be voting
well
my understanding whilst being on air
somewhere else is that the uh the
government have put forward an amendment
to that uh i i physically haven't seen
the whole amendment yet so i can't
comment on on that but my
further understanding from speaking to
other people is that i suspect what will
happen is the whole house will unite
behind one of those versions tomorrow
and it will probably go through
so at some point because the amendment
it appears is is kicking it slightly
down the road so perhaps after the sue
grey report is published you believe
that whatever happens with the amendment
or not at some point the prime minister
is going to end up being investigated by
the privileges committee
well well i mean look you know the prime
minister has said consistently said and
and this is very different to the to the
law breaking that you know there's two
very separate issues here uh there's a
law breaking which is where i've called
for him to resign
and then there's this issue where there
are people saying that he has uh shown
contempt to the house of commons that's
what this process is about tomorrow um
and as i said to the prime minister
personally yesterday is that look you
know you've been saying all along that
you didn't knowingly break the rules and
at face value i accept that because i
have to
um but if that's the case then what's
the issue with self-referral to the
privileges committee anyway so you know
let's just get it out in the open uh and
i suspect that's what's gonna happen
tomorrow
um and just finally so you uh of course
think that boris johnson effectively
should stand down you believe that as a
lawmaker he can't break the laws that
would leave a vacancy i'm guessing you
don't think that rishi sunak should fill
that vacancy as he has already
accepted a fine as well
you you you may or may not know but as
well as calling for the prime minister
to resign i also call for the chancellor
to resign too because he's part of that
decision-making process just like i did
when dominic cummings went up to barnard
castle uh a year or so ago um it is that
simple for me um
look
when we're nowhere near that point yet
of of looking for a new leader and we're
you know it's definitely clear that the
prime minister doesn't appear to be
resigning so let's deal with that when
we get there you say we're not at the
point of choosing for a leader but you
are with respect calling for the prime
minister to resign which would lead a
vacancy so who would you think should
fill it uh well we'll have to wait and
see who puts the names forward at that
point
if we get to that point and when we get
to that point uh but we're definitely
not at that point i mean i think there's
10
mps on the conservative benches that
have come out publicly and said the
prime minister should uh resign even to
get a vote of confidence or no
confidence i should say in the prime
minister um
we have to have 54. uh so we're a it's a
numbers game we're a long way from that
process and then of course the prime
minister will probably uh win that vote
anyway so uh you know
let's wait and see what's going to
happen briefly how many other mps do you
think are in your position conservative
mps uh with these deep misgivings if you
like about boris johnson continuing in
this job are we talking a handful are we
talking dozens
how many are we talking well there's ten
so far come out publicly so i i dare say
there are more uh but like a lot of
people they are waiting to see what's
going to happen they'll wait to see
what's going to happen what the
direction from the party is tomorrow i
suspect like i said earlier on uh there
will be some agreement with the
opposition parties about what we
actually do today
let's wait and see
okay thank you very much craig whitaker